everyone who lives in Berchtesgaden
knows hans and stung gossamer he's been
working for the national park since it
was established in 1978 he shows guests
around the historical old town and gives
talks on his home region if anyone knows
their way around Berchtesgaden gets him
good as gold
hello I'm Hans and I was born here and
back to scar Dhin so I'm a
dyed-in-the-wool back to scarda now I
have an addiction and that's to my
hometown the Magnificent nature and the
wonderful culture and I'd like to show
it to you so come along satan kim smith
his first recommendation is the house of
the mountains that's the national parks
information and education center a
permanent exhibition helps visitors to
understand the nature here from the
bottom of lake connect say to the top of
Botsman mountain the message is simple
get to know nature preserve it and
protect it the same that you hear in
here we are in the National Park Center
you'll find a very modern exhibition
here designed for all your senses your
eyes ears and fingers you can touch all
the animals on display here in fact
you're encouraged to unfasten you sold
us out
how big is an eagle's nest what plants
grow in the ALMS and on the steep
mountain slopes how do groundhogs spend
the winter on the upper floor devoted to
Botsman mountain a video shows the
beauty of nature in all four seasons our
second recommendation the salt mine in
Berchtesgaden part of it is open to the
public
protective clothing is required in the
mines even for Hans
once the visitors are suited up a driver
picks them up on the mine train and
takes them 600 metres deep into the
mountain
underground a statue of Saint Barbara
welcomes visitors she's the patron saint
of miners the Sunspear
salt mining is the foundation of back
discuss salt has been mined here since
1517 and it's still done actively today
with some one thousand tons extracted
daily tonin um talk the demonstration
mine goes into technical detail these
slides are part of the mines history
they used to funnel workers and
materials into the galleries below now
they're a source of fun for the tourists
another highlight is a lake that
reflects the gallery ceiling as if in a
mirror
a laser show accompanies the trip across
the lake on a raft
after an hour spent deep underground a
lift and the mine train take the group
back to the light of day
the hotel Edelweiss and it's aptly named
panorama restaurant on the terrace
is our hosts third recommendation hunch
tango singer has arranged to meet a
friend here they're going to enjoy an
authentic Bavarian delicacy not only is
the view here wonderful but the food's
delectable too I can especially
recommend the venison from local forests
with wheat beer that's the various
liquid bread Cheers
bands roast it's a good idea to bring a
hearty appetite this is the perfect way
to end a day in Berchtesgaden